uh I was at Fenway Park over the weekend
for a baseball game and I put up on my
Instagram david dot Pakman a picture
from my seats at Fenway Park I basically
always sit in the right field grandstand
I love Fenway Park I grew up going there
I know you've been there many times
jason i love going there in spite of the
horribly uncomfortable seats in spite of
the obstructed view which you can see in
this picture all that stuff doesn't
bother me what is really increasingly
disturbing to me is just the rampant
corporatism at sporting events and over
the years first it was one company logo
on the left field green monster and then
it was 2 company logos and then it was
three and then it was the actual seats
on the Green Monster were sponsored by
someone and then the scoreboard was made
possible by someone else and blah blah
blah blah blah you can't go to the
bathroom at fenway park without being
exposed to corporate sponsors and I it's
been a couple years since i went to a
game so is particularly jarring every
inch of that place is made possible by
or sponsored by some major corporation
you think somehow through this the see
prices might go down right it would bite
way up at one point was five dollar
bleacher seats for the fifty dollars now
I think what I recall is that some years
ago you could get day of standing room
only seats against the Yankees 4 15
bucks and they're now up to something
like fifty five dollars if I recall
correctly now that may have been a read
not the face value that might have been
the resale price I don't exactly
remember but it's bad it's really really
bad and you can check out this picture
on my Instagram account also i put out
on instagram a behind-the-scenes picture
of last week's durian experiment and
there were people who thought that this
was some kind of dead animal or maybe
something from a coral reef that i took
a picture of this is a fruit called
Durie in which we tried there were many
people who were triggered from traumatic
experiences on public transit in Asian
countries where some cities have now
banned durian on buses people wrote to
me saying oh I lived in Thailand in some
specific part of Thailand you're not
allowed to bring durian on because of
the vile smell that it emanates and I
certainly experienced that there was no
doubt yeah kind of did
like there was a dead animal here a
little while and I was I was in their
side of the rooms I'd get the full
effect but I know there is a cause of
headaches and other nauseated kind of
feelings on there's other rooms Rachel
reported heart palpitations after and
lightheadedness yeah so all those
pictures and more on my Instagram
account follow me at david dot pakman